نجت هذه البلده من لحظات رعب زلزال كهرمان
مراش لكن الماسي التي تسبب بها وصلت الى
كولاف هووك فتشنا عن احد الناجين ووجدنا
طاحه
سقطت على الارض وشعرت انني في تابوت لم
اكن استطيع التنفس تساقط الركام وعلقت
تحتها رفعت راسي لادرك ان منزلنا قد تنهار
يرفض طه دخول المنزل باتت الخيمه منزله
يخشى اي باغته زلزال اخر
نفس علقت في مكان ضيق جدا جسمي محشور تحت
الركام بالكاد كنت اتنفس احسست انني على
وشك الموت بمرور الوقت استنفذت قواي عندها
قلت انني لن اخرج حيا فقررت ان اسجل رساله
لعائلتي
بقي طه طويلا تحت الركام حتى اعتقد انها
النهايه وانه سيموت وهو في السابعه عشره
من عمره فسجل هذا الفيديو
شوف
لا تزال الارض تهتز اسال الله ان يغفر
ذنوبي ان بقيت على قيد الحياه فلدي الكثير
لاحققه مازلت في مقتبل العمر
قدمي اليمنى لا تتحرك
محمد كما صليت على ابراهيم وعلى ال
ابراهيم اللهم صل على محمد وعلى ال محمد
كما صليت على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم
انه زلزال ثامن اشعر بالارتجاج
نشطها وقتل الزلزال عمه مع زوجته واولاده
ليدفنوا في مقبره البلده في اليوم الحادي
عشر للكارثه لا يذهب طه الى اديمان
المدينه التي خسر فيها الكثير نحن سنذهب
اليها
سنفتش عن المبنى الذي علق طه تحت انقاضه
توجهنا الى اديمان ومن بين مئات المباني
وجدنا منزل طه تحول الى اطلال
سيحتاج طه الى وقت طويل ودعم نفسي ليتخطى
ما مر به ولا يمكن لاي منا ان يدرك شعور
العالقين تحت الانقاض الذين دفنوا احياء
لايام او لساعات قبل انتشالهم
وربما ما يبقى في الذاكره فقط كلمه طه
يعني لماذا
ياتينا الموت بخته سلام خضر الجزيره